[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
well I'm asking the question should I
get back on Instagram should I finally
still asking that question you're back
on Instagram I've been asking this
question for a number of years and I
just thought this would be a great forum
to finally make a decision because I've
been thinking about Instagram a lot more
lately it hasn't lost steam you know you
think it might be it might be here to
stay
I you know the background and I've asked
you to get into it but just how many
years I have I've been off Instagram
about six gosh six years since I've been
on Instagram and it's still happening I
got family friends general loved ones
who are instagramming it up I mean I I'm
a digital creator for goodness sakes it
seemed I just feel embarrassed that I'm
not on Instagram like but so I've been
thinking about it at a higher frequency
and I also think like end of last year
beginning of this year it's one of those
like maybe the new year is the time for
me to think about instagramming again I
don't know so I'm just saying I've been
thinking about it and read I just want
to ask you just to help me think this
through so we don't have to have another
discussion about it maybe at the end of
this the answer's no shut up about it
and just give up just give up even
thinking about it
Barbara get out of the trash you know
your dog sits I love how you you yelled
into the mic for Barbara to get out of
the trash because she can't hear you
better
well here's the thing your dog sits
nicely in your lap my dog is just he's
just exploring the territory around here
I'm just hoping that she'll get she
learn everything she wants to and sit
down they've had a big day
just hanging out in our office they had
their hopes up that like it would be
really exciting hanging out at work
together and they realized oh it's kind
of boring here's like our kids to be
done here's my perspective on this just
the sort of the beginning of my
perspective and can you say something to
them if like they could care less about
me getting on Instagram that's like
that's what my perspective is going to
encompass great right because I feel the
need for that yeah yeah in one sense I
would say this isn't like you're
deciding to start a side gig
this isn't like you're talking about
doing something that is going to in any
real significant tangible way alter your
lifestyle or the lifestyle of anyone
that you are you come in close contact
with okay you're talking about
activating not even beginning for the
first time but activating a social media
platform that the majority of people in
the Western world probably already are
on mm-hm and I disagree with a lot of
what you've already said okay and I'm
prepared to explain it later but keep
going so what I'm saying is I think that
is sort of the sort of that's the
perspective that I bring to this okay is
that it really isn't a big deal just
post a photo or don't just come back but
at the same time you know what we talk
about it for an hour we can get an
episode of your biscuits I I've thought
a lot about this I have lots of hopes
fears concerns there's a lot wrapped up
in this for me and I just need I process
it but I also think that it's not just
about me it might also be about you or
about loved ones of yours and they're
talking to me are you talking to them
I'm talking to them Oh in it what's your
relationship with social media and
specifically what are the does Instagram
represent a threat to your purse
well being I think that's a component of
this and like I said I have thoughts
about that as well
all right well for how it would relate
to you but we can get into that but do
you want me to kind of give the but give
it a little background please do please
kind of bring me and everybody else up
to speed on where we where we last left
me did that come out right where we left
me last on Instagram well just for I'm
gonna give it some full context here
okay I know it's a little strange that
I'm using a laptop to access an
Instagram account but I have multiple
tabs open because I you know I wanted to
explore this in detail all right so you
know it does make sense in my own brain
now link you posted your first or at
least the first picture that is on your
feed I'm assuming is it does this strike
you as the first picture yeah because
some people start earlier and then they
go back and delete you didn't do that I
haven't done that now I've done some
deleting of other things which I'll get
to later you posted on July 25th 2013
Wow 2013 so I so five and a five and a
half years ago not quite six years ago
this is when I joined this is your first
post ever I remember this day we were
shooting what was this YouTube rewind
YouTube rewind you have for the like the
Anaconda music video hold on but why did
you shoot that why did you post that in
July 25th was this a reap was just like
you access this from your I might have
posted it when rewind came out or I I
don't know any wine doesn't come out in
the middle of the summer July no no I
thought he said January so yeah I don't
know maybe we were shooting it that
early are you sure this was rewind I
think we went to it was a YouTube set
that was built for people to shoot
different types of things for their
channels and so I was wrong about that
this this is just a this is just a
jungle set build at the YouTube space
when we happen to be there for another
reason I hear here's Ross say this is a
great start test this was a great stuff
to your Instagram I'm holding a rub and
my captain is we be clubbin I mean it's
it's got a built-in joke you know some
tongue-in-cheek punny humor interesting
location the club is well framed and in
the foreground you took the photo so
don't oh yeah Rhett really framed the
photo very well and focused on the club
which was you know brings all the
attention to the club which is the butt
of the joke keep in mind the listeners
can't see this so let's not dwell too
much on the picture itself okay
well I'm trying to let you picture it in
your own mind okay now just for
comparison's sake and I'm gonna I'm the
control group I'm the guy who is still
on Instagram yeah okay
you got a club picture I started
Instagram two and a half years before
you did it interestingly November 10th
2011 well that's not two and a half
years that's a year and a half or store
almost I I hmm um bar was now yelping
she's whining she wants listen just sit
down we we're just having a conversation
why is she staring at the door she wants
to leave just lie down no no what he's
out there she's ignoring you hmm
she'd rather stare at a wall than be
with we'll see how long that lasts
we might have to get Jenna to come get
her I posted a picture no caption I I uh
I came out of the gate route not hot at
all no caption whatsoever but a lot
earlier than me okay and in had a wig
picture now I don't know exactly why at
that point when I made the decision to
get on Instagram you didn't because
typically when we because we embark on
things like this we typically do them
together it was a new thing and I'm like
I don't want to do another thing another
thing that will probably fizzle out I
mean we there'd been some things and
they just fizzled out I can't remember
what they are so it does take a little
bit more from you to kind of get your
yeah get your mojo up to the place where
you want to actually participate
but I got only broke and I did it and
then you posted let me get out of this
first of all I just will comment that
your next two photos were faces of
sculptures like one's a Lego sculpture
and one is a series of baby dolls put
together to make a lion pretty crazy
it's um it's a mask made out of baby
doll arms I think that was at a museum
or something newest it was an amazing
Medusa sculpture from your vacation in
the Exploratorium in San Fran he
actually shortened San Fran you could
have put SF he probably would do that
now so a vacation pic so is she like
she's scratching the door now my dog
it's just she's like she's being held
captive okay and then not I mean a
handful of post later I mean not more
than thirty posts later it was November
30th so about two and a half years later
no no no no it's the same year it's 2013
what same year what it's November 30th
2013 you didn't last a year it was it
was from July to November on this wave
year here and interestingly your last
post I'm a mountain top it's like you're
saying goodbye you know what I'm saying
it's just like it's not even a picture
of you it's just a picture of the sky
and it's just like you're like I'm going
into the ether yeah and I got thirty two
thousand likes on that thing that's
pretty good right you have thirty two
thousand likes on that because it's your
last posts Oh
I mean I'm how many followers do I have
I don't even know that you currently
have four hundred and seventy six
thousand followers almost half a million
followers how many do you have
uh-oh thanks for asking first I've got
to scroll through all my mini posts and
the funny thing is is I don't even post
that often I have one whoa million got a
million followers
notice what happens when you continue to
participate hobbit day
I don't know the exact number because
there's one emmalin i don't have a
competitive bone in my body so this is
not even this is not resonating with me
I'm just like surprised
so you've you've doubled me but maybe I
could get competitive and that could be
something to motivate but I will say
that you know just doing the math on
this that I've definitely put in more
than twice the effort and I'm still only
twice as many followers right so you
actually have done but it's yeah you are
on for a year I can look at you and tell
I mean I've aged aged quite a bit you're
instagramming habit has taken its toll
man look at me look at how spry Allah I
said that this is the Delta you have you
have half a million more followers but
you gonna die a lot sooner than me and
if it comes to natural causes
I well here's the thing I have 416 post
which is not a lot over a period of what
we're going on eight years now you had
51 or 51 posts okay so if it's 51 not
too bad pretty good but yeah that's
where you left it and we've talked a lot
about you coming back and we've made a
lot of fun of your final photo and weed
that we actually did a recurring and by
recurring I mean I think we did it twice
segment we couldn't even keep doing that
on whatever season of good mythical
morning when we started making all those
videos whatever that was yeah we started
making the segment 40 forgotten people
people were hating on the segments and
hating on that particular segment which
was like a tongue-in-cheek bit of like
hey vit what picture is gonna bring me
back on Instagram what am I gonna post
because I'm gonna come back I am
determined to get back on Instagram
continue to help me out guys I want you
to tweet using hashtag links perfect
Instagram with your suggestion of what
my return to Instagram I believe in you
don't do it don't hold back
and then the segment went so poorly that
I just like this is a sign and I'll get
back on Instagram and we were not
actually we were actually at that time
we were just building towards you coming
legitimately coming bad I made a
decision to come back and we were just
gonna do that bit in order to do it but
it never happened and I just back
pocketed it and I just I suppress it and
just been something that's just been
lurking and lingering yeah okay well
we're gonna come back in a second and
we're going to get behind what why this
is such a white loom so large in your
mind yeah what's the psychology I have I
have I have a list of problems with
Instagram that I'm gonna need you to
address okay and then we got if there's
a way forward and we're gonna have to
collaboratively find it but we're gonna
have to navigate some problems that I
believe are common to most anyone who is
on or considering being on Instagram
okay and I while you while I take my dog
out of here because she obviously
doesn't want to be here you can tell
people where they can get these mugs
okay mythical nuts store is the place to
get the official ear biscuit mug check
it out it's it's speckled you know it's
it's freckled like Ke$ha in the summer
you know get yours now
I love freckles I think it's great so
much so that I requested that they be on
this mug get this one alone get it with
the L tap and the official good mythical
morning mugs they all work together as a
set or separately there's lots of other
stuff over there at mythical dodge store
so go on over there rep your squad and
that's us the mythical [ __ ] mythical
dot store and we're back now in the time
that it took Barbra me to take Barbra
out she started her own Instagram
account I mean it was that easy this
it's really it's that easy link well
it's probably even easier to get back on
but it's not without its pitfalls I
think the first thing psychologically
that the problem that I have with
Instagram is that I think it traps
people into seeming or actually becoming
or being self-important or braggy it
traps people into seeming like brat like
they're bragging or humble bragging a
part and parcel with any
post on social media not just Instagram
I think at its core I just there's this
implied assumption and I could be wrong
about this this is just how I feel about
it okay that an implied assumption that
who I am or what I'm doing or the
specifics of what I'm sharing that
people would be interested in it you
know so it's hey look at me
I I met a celebrity I ate a cannoli hmm
I am at a cool party isn't my baby or my
dog cute or yes
or it just seems like you're sending a
message that I think I'm good-looking
enough to assume that you would enjoy
looking at a picture that I took of my
own face they call that a selfie yeah
you know so it's like self-consciousness
that Wells up at the moment I'm thinking
about anything I'm gonna post what it
doesn't have to be a selfie sometimes
you can hire a professional photographer
to take a picture of you in a and a
striking fruit themed suit on the shores
of Mexico now I ain't trying to pick on
you I'm just talking about myself here
and what goes through my mind I'm proud
of them I'm proud of every photo I'm
especially proud of that one but it's
I'm okay I actually what you're saying
and so is it that the isn't that the
what underline like the core message of
anything that you pose is I assume that
you're interested in me or this way yeah
I have I have a number what your
perspective is not wrong because that is
especially for a lot of people maybe the
majority of people sort of the subtext
of Instagram uh-huh but you say this as
someone who makes their living on
YouTube yeah that there's some okay I'm
seeming irony in that
seems like it's not adding up yeah it
seems like my job is hey look at me
look every day go to youtube and look at
my face along with your face and laugh
at it isn't what I'm doing funny isn't
what I'm doing interesting look at me
look at me so is it really while I
assume that you want to look at what
we've planned yeah but it feels
different because I feel like what we're
saying with everything we create and
good mythical morning is you know the
top example is I feel like the
underlying messages I assume that you
will enjoy what we've decided to make
now it just happens to feature my face
prominently sometimes eating and gagging
on things I understand I understand
there's a there is a so it's like there
is a slight distinction there like I I
get that it's not it's not look at me
it's being entertained by what we've
created or be entertained by me which
leads to my second point which is you
can have an Instagram account that
operates on a different principle lots
of people do it in fact a number of the
Instagram accounts that I'm going to
recommend to you to follow and maybe all
of them are not personality based no so
so I okay go ahead so what I'm saying is
that that's one way to see Instagram
some people you know we talked about
this before I think I and I don't know
if I've held to this but I established I
pulled it out of my butt as I always do
some ratio that I thought was
appropriate for selfies to pictures of
things on Instagram and I thought I
think I said something like 20% now all
everyone will tell you every analytics
person will tell you that pictures of
your face are going to perform the best
and get the most followers so once you
starts you can't get into this place
where you do want to get more followers
everything sort of pushes you in the
direction of taking pictures of yourself
but you don't have to do that you could
you could take pictures of things I mean
your last picture is a picture of the
sky and
Mountains you could just be the sky
mountains man so I don't necessarily
think that it has to be all about you
but even if it is today the way that I
see Instagram is you know how like when
you're in you're like in a hotel in the
city like you're in a hotel in New York
mm-hmm and if you're like me oh I've
been in a hotel in new you you're in
you're in a you're in a high-rise hotel
Oh high-rise in it and you go to the
window and you do what at night look out
of it and what are you looking at the
city you're looking at what streets no
there's a building across the street and
there's what in the building oh I'm
looking straight across yeah
a naked couple well I did see no I I've
actually never looked across I always
think that I'm a look I'm like wow
there's a there's another high-rise
building right there that's an apartment
I'm gonna look across there and I'm
gonna see naked people but I never have
I keep looking
hold on you well but no but never happen
don't you remember the time that me and
you and Stevie and our all of our
significant others were together on a
balcony yeah okay in Manhattan and then
we looked across to the apartment across
from us and there were people doing
something and it took us about 10
minutes to figure out they were playing
cornhole indoors inside yeah but it was
not easy to figure out who it was
actually further away yeah because I are
they bowling are they doing charades
yeah yeah they're playing indoor
cornhole what desperate and actually
situation and actually that's the that
fits perfectly into the way that I see
what Instagram is Instagram I have to
explain this is because looking at naked
people I don't think you can do that on
Instagram no you can't yeah yeah female
nipples you can't look at female nipples
but you can look at male nipples all you
want because male nipples you know
dysfunctional okay I'll need to write
that down
but in fact some there was there was a
let's not get off on a nipple tangent
what I'm just saying there there's a
woman
that took male nipple pasties and put
them over her own nipples okay as a way
to say was why what's the big freaking
difference between the two nipples and I
think I know I mean how'd that go over I
mean I don't know I don't really know
the story okay well I'm glad you told
the first half of it but it was a little
protest explain to me how you're seeing
Instagram through the lens of people
playing cornhole in an adjacent
high-rise building anyone who has their
window open and is doing something in an
apartment or a hotel in New York City is
basically saying take a look at what I'm
doing right now right and so that's why
I don't feel weird about just like and
it's not like I'm like looking over
there trying to find something it's just
like you kind of like I feel like I'm in
a movie sometimes and I'm like looking
across and like oh I'm seeing it's just
like when Letterman used to call that
woman he would look across his office
and he would see the woman and yeah and
she was in the window she was working
and it's a real woman and they ended up
having like a long-term friendship I
think that Instagram is like your window
your curated window to the world it's
like saying I'm doing this right now
I'm playing cornhole right now and I
want I want and I don't care who knows
in fact my friends who know which window
I live in who know which apartment if
they want to see me playing cornhole
it'd be cool for them to take a peek
into my life at this point okay and you
can open the window and show what you
want to show within certain guidelines
and you can close the one so you're so
you're saying it's not begging for them
to look you're not lashing the lights
and yelling across the way like all over
here if you want look this way it's more
just like hey the shades are up I'm
throwing the corn bag yeah look if you
want it's up to you take it or leave it
and I also think that there is but it's
but it's not it's definitely please
leave this it is for a lot of people it
is it is for a lot of people and it is
for it is for me at times right like if
I don't there are people who
we post pictures of themselves that are
from bad angles or they look bad because
they're trying to counteract exactly the
general subtext that you're talking
about you know they'll take like a weird
picture of themselves although swing the
pendulum too ugly and I think that that
is totally fine and kudos to those
people but uh but that's but see again
they have the power to make that
decision and to show to the world what
they want to if you if your fear is that
you're gonna seem like a braggy daddy if
you start instagramming will then
approach Instagram in a different way
and I think that the first different way
that comes to my mind leads to my second
problem and that's because now it's not
just pictures but it's also stories and
there's a whole lot of functionality I
mean we do stories through the rhett and
Link account whenever we're out and
about doing something work-related or
yeah just having an adventure but I I
think well if I'm just not going to post
pictures of myself and be really
self-conscious about it then I need to
be entertaining and then I need to I
need to make this a creative outlet and
it becomes like work it literally
becomes work and to me that is the
second problem I went on well here's the
thing I I got I would get into bed and
you know like Christie's on her phone
and I'm on my phone and I've started
looking at Reddit and I'm very
entertained by that and I like I'll fall
asleep to read it on my phone I'm just
you know I think it's healthy but I look
over at Chrissy and she's laughing and
like she's looking at one of our mutual
friends Instagram feeds and this
particular person we just really enjoy
his stories and what he's posting like
the way that his in the way that he says
things and it's just it's just I love it
it just makes me happy that connected
like seeing this person stories that is
just a friend and like I'm looking over
Christie shoulder and we're just like
having a blast
looking through the feed
and then I realized and she wants to get
to something else and I'm like no no no
go further go further she's like well I
want to look at this and I'm like you
know what I have Instagram on my phone I
can look at this on my phone right now
like I'm there no barriers to me doing
that and then I pull up my phone and I
open it up and it's first time I had
open Instagram five years and I look at
it I'm like my whole feed is just
populated with course people that I
follow right and only those people
that's how it works
right well that particular yeah yeah
your feed and you can go to explore and
you can see other stuff but yeah I'm
looking at it and I'm realizing
everything in my feed its youtubers and
then I go to the Who am I following tab
and I was falling like a hundred and
eleven people and the vast vast vast
majority of those people were all
youtubers like the moment I got on
Instagram way back then and posted that
Club picture I just went on and started
following youtubers once you follow one
or two it's like they suggest you and
and so now I was just all of a sudden I
experienced just an avalanche of anxiety
that like oh well what are all these
people doing it was this it became this
anxiety of competition in comparison hmm
which I I think is a general problem
with a lot of people on Instagram right
just there's an anxiety of competition
and comparison am I is my life as
interesting as this person is my face as
cool-looking as this person's is my
so-and-so is my dog you know Harry Harry
in the right places you know so you're
getting all that but for me I don't
think anybody's worried about them oh my
gosh what are all these other youtubers
do mean that I feel like I should have
been doing for the past five years you
know it became a business thing and I
totally forgot about looking looking at
our friends Instagram story you know
and I was like you know what this makes
me mad and if I'm ever gonna get back on
this thing this is the problem hmm
and I just I started clicking on follow
unfollow I clicked unfollow this one one
six lanes and 11 times because I'm
followed and I was was cuz what's that
it was like the vast majority it just
left a handful of people and I was like
screw it I'm gonna follow them to
unfollowed you it was weird it was weird
you know and I it felt good it felt
healthy it felt like the right thing for
Mel good to go on your Instagram account
that you don't use and unfollow everyone
yes you might need to see a therapist
yeah and I am right now and you're as
close as we're getting at this point but
yeah nice and I can say that just before
you think I'm making fun of mental
health because I do see a therapist okay
and I do think that there's a
therapeutic absolutely there is
something that I think I was talking to
a therapist instead of you we'd be I do
think there's there's a great note right
I think there's something to crack open
here because your concerns are all valid
right the first thing you mentioned
about feeling like this is all about
being self-absorbed I could meet someone
who I could have a friend who wasn't you
who wasn't an entertainer in any way and
they would be like I'm out on Instagram
because I feel like it just makes me
think about myself too much and it's
superficial and it feeds into a part of
me that I don't want to feed and I would
be like I respect that man that's cool
mm-hmm so that's a valid thing now my
counter to that I've already stated it
is that well you live a self-absorbed
self-promoting life already thank you
and hopefully I think part of being a
healthy entertainer is separating and
this isn't easy this is easier said than
done
separating your self-worth from people's
perception of you and so I think that's
the kind of the way that I see Instagram
at this point and kind of and and
hopefully bypass at least some of that
I'm not obviously I still worry
people think of me and that's why I
posted you know the watermelon pick and
the best pick of the bunch right but I
also know and I just say I and for me
let me finish
for me that I'm posting that the pie
chart of reasons for why I posted the
watermelon pic the majority I truly
believe this is because I think that it
is entertaining I think people will find
people will get a laugh or people will
people will get something it will in the
way that I consume Instagram I will be
contributing to it and you know III read
Yelp reviews I don't write you up
reviews I take but I don't give but on
Instagram I take and I give I'm
receiving the feeds and I'm feeding into
the feed and I and I'm doing it because
I feel like I'm giving somebody
something that they can enjoy on some
level giving them insight into my life
and something that I think is worthy of
showing people I'm opening the window
and saying hey we're playing cornhole
today I don't post a whole lot but so I
so I think you can overcome that but
with that with that I mean the thing
that I need to overcome is I I don't
think I could ever post that watermelon
swimsuit photoshoot because I would be
afraid that it would be misinterpreted
as well I think I think I look great in
this watermelon bathing suit and under
the guise of I think that it's funny but
it's not but but people are just gonna
say that I look good in it yeah but that
but then so then I'm concerned about so
I'm concerned I'm not good so why do I
don't want people to dictate what I feel
about myself but when you make a
decision to wear the clothes that you
wear on every the clothes that you wear
every day what are you are you like nah
man I wear what I works cuz I don't cuz
it makes me feel good if you if you wore
what you were cause it made you feel
good you'd wear sweats all the time you
make a decision to put clothes on
because it's external man it it cuz it
shapes people's perception of you so and
then when I make a decision I'd be on
camera I think that's one thing but like
when you're posting a photo
Instagram it kind of the the number of
reasons the number of potential motives
that someone could guess shrink a lot
more than the number of motives
associated with what you're wearing when
you're just walking around town but we
but anything that you do in your I think
you're you're making a distinction
between showing a picture or showing a
slice of your life and then what you do
every single day which is entertain
people and you are saying I think I've
got something interesting to say I think
I've got something interesting to show
you if me and you are going and doing a
concert it's like we think we're
interesting enough for you to buy a
ticket to come and see us we even think
we're interesting enough for you know
100 or 200 people to pay even more money
to come just to get a picture with us
mm-hmm this is an incredibly
self-focused self-promoting mentality
that we already adopt as an entertainer
and and what I'm saying is that you of
all people should be able to make that
transition it's like I said if you were
just somebody who if you were just uh
you know a banker I got lots of banker
friends and you were like you know
that's I don't like that I don't like to
be the center of attention I don't like
to dance on the dance floor in front of
everybody I don't like to tell stories
about my life but you like to do all
those things you love to tell the story
tell stories about your life no I'm
saying if a banker said that oh yeah you
lost my analogy if a banker said that to
me and he was like and so that's why I
don't do Instagram but you love to tell
stories
yeah you love to dance you love to be
the center of attention in in in in in
the same way that I do maybe even more
so than me in all kinds of life
situations but I mean you're saying that
all of it I like autographed it as a as
the thing so then that is my second
barrier you can craft it perfectly it's
but that takes work open the window for
a second right but that takes so that's
the second point is it takes the work of
how do i craft this it's the reason why
I don't tweet is cause like now this
engineer I'm like is this funny enough
like
like I got to come up with something
funny I've got that there's a pressure
of performance when I just need to like
zone out or like to take it easy yeah I
probably relate to this so I want to
find a way forward that is not you know
I don't want it to seem like look at me
and I don't want it to seem like work
where I've I've said hey this is not
about looking at me this is about and
this is also not about look at what I've
come up with to entertain you because
that's too that's too much working and I
like I don't I just don't want to add
another place where I go well okay so I
think on the Twitter front that knows of
my own those are my two problems those
are my two barriers to getting back on
is to you feel like we've addressed the
first one what I'm trying to say is
you're not wrong but you've made an
unnecessary unnecessary distinction
you've cordoned off this this area of
Instagram and said that this is somehow
different when what I'm saying is that
so many aspects of your personal and
public life is already about look at me
why not just throw one more into the and
do it in a healthy way that if it's
gonna make you if it is gonna make you
more self-absorbed then don't do it but
what I'm saying is I don't think it will
I think that you're already you know the
correct amount of self-absorbed that it
takes to be an entertainer but not so
self-absorbed that you become a
self-destructive entertainer yeah I
don't think I do not think that me
posting pictures on Instagram is going
to negatively impact me psychologically
okay I I just think it's it's a hang-up
I don't want to be thought of as a guy
who thinks that you want to look at it
okay I want to be I want you thought is
a guy that makes you that thinks you
want to laugh with or at him but if you
were so but you're the first person on
earth to be thinking about Instagram but
everyone has an Instagram account every
single person that you know intimately
you know well yeah has yeah an Instagram
account so you're in good company and
I've got doesn't make you weird or
self-absorbed yeah and maybe I just
don't take maybe I just want take
selfies sure well you could do Casey
nice that came out with that company
that Annie meme and it was all about
what you were seeing that worked well
it's just I think it didn't work I think
it were I think it actually worked very
well for Casey in the long run it didn't
work for CNN bought it but I think the
reason it didn't work is because last
night I don't think that's what people
people are not necessarily just
interested in what you're seeing they're
kind of interested in seeing you so
anyway the I'm motivated to get back on
because you know my kids are on there
it's like I want to be able to spy on my
let's get to that but I don't want to
but I want to address your second point
which i think is I relate to your second
point I really to both of your points
the first point I feel like I just
bypass speak personally because I was
like I don't I don't see why this is any
different than anything else I do the
second point of it feeling like work I
really relate to I especially because
I'm first of all I don't post a lot at
all yeah my frequency is like a photo a
week if that and my stories well I'm
starting to do a little bit more well
I'll get into that second but Twitter as
a point of comparison you know I
followed different comedians and I see
what they tweet and it makes me mad
because I'm like you know what because
you hate calm I do I feel like I do a
lot of things well and I usually can
kind of set my mind on something and
figure it out
yeah but and I actually fancy myself a
pretty good writer
and I actually are a good writer and I
actually fancy myself a pretty good joke
writer jokes in the context of a script
what I cannot really do well is joke
tweet and
that some of these comedians can you
know I just like I definitely can't like
one of my favorite favorite accounts
Meghan Amrit Imran Imran however you say
her last name and she's a writer in here
in town and like she just had a tweet
that was r.i.p 2018 2018 to 2018 so good
and then I was looking at her feet and
she was tweeted something like you ever
wonder if all our all of our muscles
have the ability to taste but the tongue
is the only one we put food on and again
I'm just like and she better be good at
it cuz she is a writer I know that is
what she does but I feel better you know
so what have you decided that you're not
good at it
I well I oscillate man when it comes to
Twitter I think to myself I think the
way forward for me with Twitter is just
don't put pressure on yourself see
Twitter as an extension of your brain
again it's like it's this thing where
you can occasionally just open it up and
share a thought sometimes it's serious
sometimes it's observational sometimes
it's funny sometimes you're definitely
trying to make a very specific joke
about something maybe you're so
responding to somebody but I feel like I
have a similar hang up with Twitter
because I feel like I am known as a
funny person so therefore I better have
a funny Twitter but also because it
takes me time just didn't think I'm
working on a lot of other things and
contributing creatively to a lot of
other things and so I kind of feel like
I have a limited amount of creative
energy and you know that's how I think
if I'm funneling it into Twitter so but
with Instagram because it's not it's not
curated in the same way like tweets are
like I have to formulate a thought in
its it's more work than like I am in
this situation right now I could take a
picture of it yeah I feel like I could
you know at Instagram then Twitter and
I'm I think I'm done with tweeting I
think Twitter to me especially if
if you succeed at getting me back on
Instagram this is entirely up to you
then Twitter to me is just gonna be
coming interaction with people who were
tweeting at me
so it's conversational you know because
I'm on the app because it's it's a news
source for me you know look at the
moments and like it's a fun way to kind
of get the news it's a glow it's a
global conversation around and then with
one click over the curated it down to
the people that you that you want to
hear from because I follow so many I had
the automatic refile on Twitter so every
fan who followed me for like years and
you we automatically followed them back
so that is useless to me now - till I
unfollowed I did not report I don't do
that serves ago so my feed it has so
many people just tweeting about their
own lives that like I I can look at the
ATS where people want to talk to me or
you talk about or go to moment supplies
and I go to moments but so I'm just
gonna I'm giving up on trying to tweet
something funny so I guess just I don't
like to write in that way so so it is
opening the a little margin for
Instagram if you succeed well and I
think that I've I think that my
philosophy towards Twitter is becoming
I'm not gonna feel pressure if I have
something I'm like oh that would make a
good tweet we'll just tweet it without
really scrutinizing it and think yeah
much but I'm using Twitter as an example
because that sort of stage fright that
accompanies Twitter it doesn't translate
to Instagram for me so I get that
because I don't think it would for me
either
if I think I'm I don't know I guess I I
said that it would because unless I if I
can let go I just need to find a middle
ground of how I look at it where it's
not alright I am going to do something
that's like a story video that's gonna
be entertaining I'm gonna make a little
show for you here or like I'm gonna post
this picture and like I got to see how
many likes it's gonna get well and or
something then like Internet's and so if
it could become a generally a genuinely
fun outlet for me like the way that I'm
on
read it like I really enjoyed the way
that I use Twitter I'm actually starting
to enjoy now once I let go of okay I've
got to I got a tweet something funny so
to me the question is but there is there
oh you just used both of those you're
just using you're just sucking both of
the life out of both of those platforms
without contributing which I do the same
thing with Reddit I don't have a I think
I have an old reddit account but I de
camión log into it well is there is
there another way forward for how I can
interact with Instagram in terms of how
I post lower threshold and what I
consume that makes it fun for me lower
the threshold threshold of what
qualifies as an interesting post I think
I need to do the same thing because I'm
over here and lean not a lot of stuff
going on on Instagram land because the
thing I'm just like I don't have
anything interesting I mean I think the
thing that people don't understand well
maybe they do is that sure we may do
this in these ridiculous notable
instagram-worthy things on our show but
that's our show and then when we're not
doing that and we're pretty much just
sitting around working and developing
things and then I go home and that's why
a lot of times my Instagram story will
just like be my dog because that's well
that's that's what I see when I walk
through the door and so well my dogs
already got an Instagram account I did
have it
I've also felt like I don't want to tell
anybody about it because I think because
my cuz like lily post stuff on it when
she post stuff about the dog on it and
I'm like I'm not I'm I just felt like
there something's gonna get posted and
there's gonna be somebody's gonna find
out where I live or something I'm very
concerned about that well I think your
kids are probably actually more equipted
managing that than we are I wouldn't
know because I'm not following them on
Instagram so that's the other thing I
need like I said I need to not spy but I
need to I mean
turns out if I'm gonna have a meaningful
relationship with my kids it's a good
piece of that pod needs to have an over
insta core
yeah but thing you don't understand is
that you're assuming that they're that
you know about all their Instagram
accounts to just give up on that for a
second let me just let me just lay out
the reality of the situation with the
teens the youth in their instagrams they
have more than one and the one that they
that you know about is not the one that
they could communicate with what yes man
Alf Instagram is that that's what that
is
well you sounds like you know more than
me a fake Instagram I've heard about
that yeah so they they have an Instagram
account because histogram makes it so
easy to just add multiple accounts and
switch between them so you have your
Instagram account that your parents
follow that you comment on publicly but
then you've got another Instagram
account which all right you know I once
and they're both on Instagram and
there's a fake Instagram and I think the
fake Instagram I don't know which is
which but whichever one that you know
why kids aren't allowed to have that
okay so you're gonna grab their phone
and look and see if they got it because
that's how they communicate with each
other they don't you know for the
longest time I was like a lot was
planning a party for his birthday and
the way that all the communication was
happening was over Instagram I was like
this is how you guys use Instagram so I
wonder you just text everybody it's like
how it'll do that that's yeah I think I
think that they they do they do text I
think he does text with some friends but
they they use the apps to communicate
with each other quite a bit and they're
not going to use the the account that
they that you know about you know maybe
they are you can't control that man just
let go let them be the youth but but but
so but I feel like we still haven't
addressed your second point I'm just to
put up to tie a bow on that they need to
find a way for that's not like work
performance performance anxiety yeah
that is so that you associate with this
I relate to that and I kind of have the
same thing but I just
first of all just say
don't care just flip a switch and don't
just don't care I think your your
account would be really interesting I
think if link not caring is pretty
entertaining
as we have demonstrated hmm I never
thought about as a career
okay well that's an interesting point
cuz I mean link overthinking has never
been entertaining that's true you're
exactly right yeah and that's all I've
been doing
in fact link over let's think of all the
things that link overthinking things has
led to it led to that really weird my
first marriage that really weird first
marriage yeah ha that really weird
speech that you gave would try when you
try to get elected that will it really
weird speech I gave at my rehearsal
dinner yeah that really weird speech I
gave at my 40th birthday party yes that
really weird speech I gave every time I
had to give a speech but think of all
the moments that you haven't thought and
how great it's gone yeah and how little
work went into it you know that link
that's why I'm here yeah I'll do the
thinking no no but you know it Stevie
actually told me the other day she was
talking about you know we we have we
have a lot of people come in to our
office and meet with us for various
things potential projects and etc and
she was telling me when we went live
this ends in a compliment premiere the
other night she was like she's like
she's like you know link is he's so good
in those meetings the way he's you know
it when it feels like things are getting
awkward and somebody they're saying
something he's like he says something
they're like loosen it up and you know
she didn't tell me that and she don't
want me to like start to get flamey
pants like whoa look at my pants on fire
um
flamie pants okay so you like try too
hard right you didn't think about
setting my pants on fire because there's
an awkward moment Stevie told me I'm
good at this and so yeah but you're not
like sitting around and calculating your
strategy or those people you're just
like they said something and you're just
saying the first thing that comes to
your mind yes oh yeah I got that from my
dad might you translate that into I mean
first of all let me just say that this
is a little
bit risky okay it's a little bit risky
but if you'll be posting like social
security numbers and like credit card
numbers and home addresses that's what
I'm like I think but I think there's a
way to do that post and it goes to
somebody that then they then they say
yes and they let it go through or not
like an operator we could probably write
here's somebody an Instagram they're
gonna be like no you're about to do
something stupid if I arrange that here
in house don't give this man a knife
kind of a thing I mean we could probably
do that here in house but I don't think
we have to I think the way that you do
it is I think that your Instagram is
linked unfiltered first of all I can't
use filters everything has to be I
didn't think that was hashtag no filter
but you but you've been you you your
initial instinct is like I'm not gonna
think about this I'm just gonna create
it and then that moment before you post
if I'm present or if your wife is
present or if one of your children is
now your children probably skip me just
give me some questions to ask myself I
don't want to have to be babysat
no no so like just like is there a
social security number say if you were
alone okay yeah if you're alone let's
just then just stop and look at it be
like okay don't don't let the filter
operate until you've created the post
don't you don't need to pre-filter
things because that's when you're
getting in your head in your and you're
locking up no just follow your instincts
but then you know what you have a chance
after you've written everything to be
like this is a good idea and at that
point the only reason you shouldn't post
something is if you think oh I didn't
think about this this could be offensive
in this way yes or uh so if it's gonna
be offensive in some way or you see you
can see my nutsack exactly you don't
have any nutsack not even a little bit
of nut sack right should make it into
the picture and Instagram will will
allow a little nut just a little peak
this action yeah
so no nut sack no female nipples all the
male nipples you want and too and so I
just think you gotta take the filter off
and just be like this is a I take
pictures this is an arena of
self-expression and that was another
thing that out that I want don't want
talk about don't see it as
work that has to be judged the great
thing is is that it doesn't matter how
active in in successful our Instagram
accounts are because thankfully we've
got this thing going as the two of us
that is very well taken care of and
actually not personally managed by the
two of us so that it's actually active
right and so that's what supports us
that's why we were able to sit here and
have this conversation in this building
this isn't our livelihood is not
dependent on people's reaction to your
Instagram so you shouldn't really worry
don't worry don't think of it as work
work as what so do you make a living
she's saying dance like no one's
watching dance like nobody's watching it
but didn't know that every once while
people are watching should I take it as
a personal like you know every once in a
while people might be able to see your
nutsack and those those times stop
dancing and delete the post what if I
treat it that only my mom is watching
because then there won't be any nutsack
gotta be weird no social security
numbers because I don't want her to have
that no but I don't think you should see
your mom as your audience because I
think it would be a very narrow all my
stories would start with hey mom yeah I
know I mean that would be a comedic
choice but it would be maybe trying to
and you know what there's probably a
comedian who's done it already
oh I mean it's like the vlogbrothers
deciding to talk to each other should I
not read the comments and likes and and
track my following just say caution to
the it's not about the results it you
you know what if you feel like you would
then begin to associate yourself worth
with the reception of your content don't
worry about that don't look at the likes
don't look at your followers now you you
might need to look at the comments again
and make sure there's because people
will usually say like nutsack if they
see it okay but other than that I
wouldn't worry about the comments I
think the other component is to make it
more fun there's also who do I follow so
that I'm drawn to the app as a user
because I do think once I'm in it then
I'm like oh I'm also gonna post
something well I think you need to I
have some recommendations give them to
me because I think I'm pretty sure that
I don't
follow anyone that could be seen as a
peer in the industry or like that's
gonna be weird dressed as a competitor
like I just don't want to watch other
other youtubers because it's gonna it's
gonna seem like oh I need to be doing
what they're doing okay you can be an
exception because you're also a friend
I'm gonna just say this is gonna be a
little bit weird of his late link does
I'll follow anybody who does what he
does which is usually what people do
because it's actually informative to be
a part of the community but if that's
I'm dancing and no one's watch the goal
here is to get you on Instagram so if
that's the way you feel about it then
I'm not gonna argue with you yeah I'm
gonna say some people may be a little
weirded out by it but that's what they
think and it's not about what they think
okay also you know Instagram is smart
and knows who you want who you look at
and keeps and sends you those posts so
you can also follow those people for the
public facing you know value of it and
then just not engage with them and then
Instagram will stop showing them to you
I think I don't know hey I who should I
follow unless don't give me any
youtubers I'm not gonna give you very
much at all I'm gonna give you just a
very small sample of the kinds of
accounts that I find the most
inspiration because I know what I do
what I follow on reddit oh like people
peeling stuff off of things
Dotson's perfect loops okay well I think
these are the same types of things the
things I enjoy most like I've shown you
stuff from this before kook slams kook
ko okay
slams kook it hopefully it's not a
derogatory term for something else but
it's a bad source of bad surfer is what
I know it as and in the context of this
account that's what it means so this is
just people who have had accidents in
the ocean and it's just a series of
people just screwing their lives up in
the ocean you know you know like this is
a good one so this is this is a
beachfront wedding oh goodness
there's a little backdrop today there is
couldn't they know that the ocean was
going to come in and crash on everything
isn't that something the oceans other
people are still sitting there so so I
mean that entertained me you know I'm
into that yeah that was I wanted to see
that alpha also feel smarter than them
I'll lean over to my wife and say check
this out this wedding that just got
rampage by a wave you just been kook
slammed alright here's another one a
similar theme Jerry of the day a Giri is
a derogatory term for a bad skier oh
gosh okay a skier who doesn't know
what's up you know is making bad
decisions on the slopes so this is
anybody who's just kind of embarrassing
themselves in general I mean I don't
know if I mean I'll just click on a
random one here this guy this guy's
skiing down he's hitting the jump what
he hits the jump and then it's just it
ends in the perfect place right the loop
ends in the right place and dude that's
it you know skis come off and nose goes
into the snow okay get that little
dopamine rush so I got the snow and I
got the ocean but there's outdoor
activities now but this is one that I
found recently that I'm very excited
about catatonic youths only ten point
seven thousand followers getting in
early and this is just this person who
has curated all of these weird musicians
like check this out
[Music]
gosh is this horrible said what about
Malibu this is a joke no it's not it's
not a joke it's not a joke
I'm gonna show you like check this one
out puff-puff of gear okay they're not
in Malibu they're a little north and San
Francisco or San Fran as I call it on my
Instagram
in this in the forest I'm an earth
warrior this is bad in the woods I'm a
warrior nature's soldier fighting for
the earth that's that's a good cause -
yeah let's go fund me and of course then
you got your me McHale Sonic Youth's
you got your meme accounts like Daquan
and you know the fat Jew okay
these are funny and my yeah Christie
shows me some of this stuff that's
that's where I'm clicking all most of
the time I mean that's there's a lot of
and not but I also didn't look into what
about dogs
I don't follow any dogs I probably
should I bet you there's a lot of dog
there's lots of dogs to follow you can
follow just dogs you can follow just
dogs that's how awesome it is okay you
you're creating it it's like moving into
a going into a hotel in New York and
then looking across the street and being
able to just digitally control the
different people who live across from
you to open their shades yes no they
open the shade but then you you put your
balls on it oh okay I I feel like I can
find and you know what hashtag ear
biscuits you make recommendations on the
Gwydir for what else I can follow on
Instagram I have to show you this this
is when sting was at some award show and
they
recovering fields of gold yeah obviously
it wasn't going well look at his
reaction oh no it's every step you take
[Music]
he's like trying he's trying to stomach
it great
now that's catatonic youths as well yeah
yeah yeah so it's just bad singing face
man he's literally shaking his head a
little bit and there's I mean this is
endless it just keeps going there's just
there's so many people who make bad
music I mean I never knew I loved it so
much
Wow look it's just endless look hours
link hours of wasting your time so you
see what I've missed
now I will say the ones the one thing we
haven't discussed is just the time
sucking pitfall and just kind of
generally dopamine expending exercise
that all social media social media is
well you know I've got a reddit pocket
and I think that I would just give some
of that to my Instagram but I just don't
think I would be on it constantly I just
don't you got a ration I mean I think if
I were gonna be on Instagram constantly
I would already have been on reddit
constantly given how much I enjoy that
so I think I'm pretty good at
compartmentalizing and I and again that
may be the fatal flaw in me like
actually being on there me but I'm
getting closer to saying I'm ready to do
this but well I have an idea for your
first post we think yeah we just have to
think I have an idea that I that I think
will address it actually in a weird way
it addresses all your concerns okay I
think that I don't think that you're
going to be able to do this if you don't
embrace posting pictures of yourself I
think that the picture will you come
back with does need to be of yourself of
your face okay oh I think you need to
come back with a selfie
come I was I think you need to come by
with a selfie because you don't you got
to come out a little bit hot man in
overcoming this and not carrying I don't
I don't know what I think I'm hot come
out hot and I think that you need to
have a real booger a real actual booger
sticking out of your nose this is bad
this is a bad idea because it takes both
of the problems that I have an Instagram
and it was this in both front and center
hey no it disarms the whole thing face
and I think it's funny that I'm doing
this we've been through this you are
funny okay
you've made a living being funny you are
funny get over it why not just make a
fart joke I mean a booger joke you can't
see a fart man okay you can't see a fart
and then you shouldn't show it heard oh
you know what i'ma prove you wrong I I
have an idea okay I'm not saying I have
my own yes that doesn't have to be the
idea because we talked about how you
don't need to think about it but I just
think that if you come out of the gate
with something that is a little
self-deprecating and it just embraces
and don't not show your face though I
think you think at least in the first 10
post you got it you got to show your
face 10 times in the first 10 post there
needs to be you showing your face once
it's what I'm saying ah I've got an idea
okay but now you're thinking about it
that's true you know actually it's a
reverse one you know what I've thought
about the I've got even think about the
time and don't even think about the
content it's just when it hits you do it
and don't occur you own everything don't
don't use my idea don't use my idea I
want do I use an idea have an idea and
the idea being formed is the post itself
- one swift motion you know what it's
you it's been very helpful
having this conversation and I think I'm
ready and I'm not gonna ask you to go
over to Instagram and follow link Lamont
which no is not my real name well
there's another thing we didn't discuss
but that's cool
should I start over I got half a million
followers I can't start over
don't start over go with that
your social-media name n when I reach a
million followers I will make my first
post back just joking
not about that this is a form of
self-expression I'm dancing like no
one's watching is this photo linked
Lamont is the post going to be all of
our don't is the post going to be up
when this podcast is live yeah I'll make
a commitment I think I'm ready
I think I'm yes when the video is live
or when the audio versions lives the
audio when this thing comes out that's
the audio okay it's at it's by the time
this comes out it's there okay I'm
excited man I don't know if I'm gonna
follow you but I don't know if I'm gonna
follow you I mean I do follow you now
but that hasn't meant anything right you
may have to unfollow dancing like
nobody's watching yeah that's that's
what I'm gonna call it I think I need a
walk that's gonna Center me I think I
need to follow it just in case there is
a nutsack you know I might just show it
to you right now if you want to see I
might need to catch the public nutsack
just in case there's a square of nutsack
a square I don't know what kind of
underwear you guys might have a square
hole in it oh it doesn't good
it doesn't alright thanks for hearing me
out I don't I don't know if this is
helpful for anybody else everybody's
like what are you talking about I'm
already on Instagram you've made now
you've made me overthink it alright but
like I said hashtag ear biscuits let me
know what you think commiserate with me
if you're if you're off don't talk me
don't talk me out of it because by the
time this comes out I've already made a
decision to be in on it and you heard it
I just made it right just uh but if you
want to recommend something that you
think I would actually enjoy on
Instagram please do that on Twitter
ironically well I guess you could do it
on Instagram yeah that's what I would
suggest in the comments of your first
post however there they should just you
just recommend in their crazy accounts
yeah
use hashtag ear biscuits that still
works on Instagram doesn't it
I believe it does it does do it and
thank you for just thank you for sitting
in on this I don't know you know I'm a
verbal processor and I just need this
space to to figure things out and I
couldn't do it without you thank you for
your help Rhett anytime any time you
want to be appreciate you want to
monetize advice for me I'm here to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]